on the surface creating a list of items
is simple enough and ER includes a
scroll view into which you can place a
linear layout that in turn arranges each
item it contains into a vertical list
note the items which have fallen off the
bottom of the linear layout and
therefore aren't currently visible in a
UI the scroll view as the name suggests
will let the user scroll through the
contents of the layout it contains but
there's a challenge associated with that
approach on a device with limited memory
and where touch responsiveness is
critically important if you are 50 items
in a list and can fit 10 items on screen
at any given time what's the minimum
number of views you'd need to create in
order to scroll through every item on
the list the answer might not be
immediately obvious but think about ways
in which you can be more efficient in
your use of the views used to display
the entire list